the controversy over Florida's education
reform law championed by Governor Ron
DeSantis protesters marched on the state
capitol this week in response to
desantis's rejection of AP
African-American studies courses in
Florida's Public Schools the Republican
Governor has also championed an
education reform law that has led to
books being pulled from classrooms and
school libraries Christian Benavides
reports on how this new law is affecting
the state's educators
Jacksonville teacher Andrea Phillips
specializes in helping third graders who
struggle to read without a diverse
variety of books that represent my
students
I can't get them interested in books
here's my book prison in January as the
state celebrated literacy week in
schools Phillips says she was told to
pack up her classroom Library we were
being directed until all books could be
vetted and we could be sure that we were
in compliance with the state laws Duval
County public schools which includes
Jacksonville said it would conduct a
formal review of all books while that
review is ongoing classrooms and school
libraries look like this under Florida's
HB 1467 law beginning this year school
books have to be reviewed by a media
specialist to ensure they're free of
pornography or certain race-based
teachings from kindergarten to third
grade the books must be free of
instruction on sexual orientation and
gender identity the school district
reminded Educators violating parts of
the law could lead teachers to be
charged with a felony they've come for
teachers so over masks they've come for
teachers over books teachers have been
called groomers Florida Governor Rhonda
Santa signed several new education laws
that he says Empower parents Floridians
want our school system to be about
educating kids not indoctrinating kids
sixth grader Jonas Walter fears one of
his favorite books may be banned from
the classroom because there's a boy who
likes a boy in the series Stephanie
Jorgensen Walter is his mother I think
what the legislation is doing is trying
to stoke fear that things are happening
in the classroom that aren't really
happening Phillips vows to continue her
fight for as long as she can these all
have to go so I have some health issues
that I don't know how much longer I'll
be in the classroom it's very upsetting
and it's really hard for me to not just
want to yell and scream about you know
how crazy this whole situation is
School libraries have thousands of books
add to that classroom libraries and
often it's just one media specialist per
School sorting through it all for CBS
Saturday morning
Jacksonville Florida
think that fear a lot of people have is
what will be erased from the classrooms
who will be represented who won't be and
you know it's trickling all the way up
to high school now we the ban on the AP
History course that is piloted now
across the country and so much more
where will it stop I think Michelle that
was very well said is to erasing who you
are erasing out of things out of books
right now and who's making those
decisions as well